[Music]
that's because you were being in ours
I'm his wife from naughty sub not some
company he's acquired I'm not the mother
[Music]
you know you're topping from the bottle
he murmurs against my lips I don't
understand what he's talking about
[Music]
she's a gyro copter you see one
day
[Music]
dios mio double crap me am a two left
feet
[Music]
desperation
I thought it was chocolate fudge brownie
sex we had
with a cherry on top but hey what do I
[Music]
she's a aerocapture easy
see
[Music]
what does that mean
does he white slave small children to
some godforsaken part of the planet
is he part of some underworld crime
syndicate it will explain why he's so
rich is he deeply religious if you but
since surely nuts he could prove that to
me right now I'm a sadist fella
I like to whip little brown hair girls
like you because you
like the crack for my bird
[Applause]
I like to come as I believe he smokes
and cranks is glorious smile up another
life so it's in full HD I'm back baby
it's gonna take more than a malfunction
in 1/35 to keep me away from you
[Music]
1:35
very easy
[Music]
you